the star of ABC's blackish also here as
part of the get real about diabetes
campaign good to see you Anthony thanks
for having me oh you bet what's really
think that all this drama with the
Warriors right now III don't know man
it'll be interesting to see what's going
on with them
dream on get your act together were you
at that game against the cliff that was
working man I had an overtime at work
but I saw the highlights and that was
like what the hell is going on I'm glad
that the Clippers pulled out to win in
overtime and you know dream on together
it says he says he's going to that's
what he has to he says he won't change
the way that he approaches the key will
not change but I'm sure that the
Warriors were changed personnel too huh
I don't I
otherwise with Durant you know what I'm
saying it you're looking at somebody who
may enter the free agency market in a
year who supposedly happy where he is
right now but because of what's
transpiring between he and and dream on
and all that he may decide to go
elsewhere if you were the franchise yes
and you had invested that much money and
time and into the KD what would you do I
would do what I what they did which was
tell dream on you over want you use yes
over the line let's pull it together for
one last season yeah the very least and
figure this thing I'm a fan of dream on
me - I love that brother I'd rather
that's what I said moment you know like
before you were coming out here is that
he it's great when he directs that in an
outward direct yeah yes you want that
guy you want that guy that gets
everybody all fired up well you want to
explode not implode
that's it yeah yeah I've been sent to
the principal's office dawg that ain't
no fun let's stay out of there and your
Clippers were the one who started this
whole thing because there cuz they're so
damn good right it was so good hey man
I'm look I'm not gonna lie I'm
pleasantly surprised at our record right
now and what we're doing I'm considering
all that we lost yes and all that we
traded away
the bomber I'm not gonna say we're
friends but I can call him up on the
phone and he'll pick up an answer what
we're friendly with the capital F and
you know even though I'm a season ticket
holder for the Clippers he invited me to
sit with him at the game the other day
and we sat and we just talked shop man
and and I love it's the first I'll Steve
Ballmer is a fan of the sport and he's
passionate about the sport and he's
passionate about his team and I'm glad
that that we have an owner like that who
was willing to do what he can to have
the best team on the floor he seems like
he's so wrapped up he would make coffee
nervous he does you sit next to him
what's it like watching again oh it's
it's it's nonstop energy man you know
and and they keep his coca-cola or Pepsi
whatever whatever drink he drinks he
keeps it just it just come so he's
caffeinated he's caffeinated brother
he's caffeinated on a carbonated liquid
and it's fine just just the energy that
that he sits there in cheers on our our
team with man I love it see cuz what
what what what you're hearing now with
LeBron back here interview is that
everyone's gonna want to come and play
with LeBron and put on the Lakers
uniform right but the Clippers when you
go into Staples mm-hmm and there's no
Clippers game going on Taylor Swift has
more banners in in Staples than the
Clippers it's true and so wouldn't you
want to come and try and create your own
legacy oh I get where are you going okay
yes okay no no I thought you everybody
to start yanking a damper I get it I
didn't pierce the valve I just think I
was just spitting truth yes yes yes and
venomously I'm following it up with a
with a little bit of dope that has been
my whole argument or point of view it
was like wouldn't you want to go
someplace and and and build your legacy
there you've already had let your legacy
established and cemented elsewhere yes
why not come here and do it you know why
play for lack of a better term in the
shadows of some of the other grades you
know when you know you can create your
great shadow
in in a clipper uniform I love dock to
dock awesome yeah you must you must see
him every now I see him all the time we
play golf together you know doc and I
have been friendly for quite some time
now yeah what's your game look like
what's your golf game look like ah it
looks horrible at the moment but you're
too busy yeah I'm too busy but when we
limit and dock dock can hit the ball he
can dock and hit the ball can't putt
worth a damn but you know he drives for
show the whole thing is you drive a sho
putt for dough yeah he'll never make the
money you'll never make the money sorry
doc I'm just gonna tell ya you're
spitting truth yeah Anthony Anderson
here on the Rich Eisen show that get
real about diabetes campaign you've been
living with diabetes for 17 years that
true yeah yes 17 years going on going on
18 years now yeah okay so what does that
like for you um you know at one point it
was it was hard it was just tough
dealing with a fluctuating glucose level
and an a1c that was through the roof but
you know with medication with exercise
with diet with a change of lifestyle
it's become manageable and I was the
first person diagnosed in my family with
diabetes but knowing what the symptoms
are and after being diagnosed with it I
look back on my childhood and my father
was a type-2 diabetic an undiagnosed
type two diabetic for almost 20 years
maybe a little bit longer and in we
unfortunately lost my father to
complications of diabetes once he was
diagnosis his quality of life was just
was just horrible because the disease
had gone so long unchecked and my mother
subsequently had become a type 2
diabetic as well so I teamed up with
novo nordisk you know to share my story
and just to bring awareness to this
disease and you know get real about
diabetes calm we also have a fake
facebook page get real about diabetes
mhm that people can go to and get
information and and learn how to to live
with this disease and maintain a healthy
lifestyle while having it because it's
if you know what you're looking for you
know what it is it is you know you just
go there and get all this information
you know for it be it for yourself or or
loved one or friend yeah no I think
Cutler right Brockman was Jay Cutler a
diabetic as well yes yes you really yeah
I don't know okay yeah Janet Laura's
dealing with don't do it during games
yeah yeah during games you have to deal
with it okay yo yeah I know that though
definitely man definitely mean I I deal
with it every day I deal with it on set
you know I have to take a shot of
insulin once a day hmm I'm also on oral
meds but you know it's it's something
that you have to constantly keep in
check or it will check you get real
about diabetes calm Anthony Anderson
here congratulations on the hundredth
episode of blackish thank you that is a
remarkable television I know your show I
know you're busy did you see the episode
or did you at least see my pictures in
my outfit I've saw that you did some
recreations of some classic videos yes
including prints it was an it was a half
hour long homage to prints yeah we did
four to five print songs and remade four
or five of his videos shot by shot with
each individual family members okay and
you think you pulled it off and I think
I think we pulled it off well you know
personally I don't I don't mind wearing
a midriff
you know I don't mind wearing a silk
mid-drift man I look like a human Domino
but you know I recreated you know the
kiss video so I've had you know from
from the bottom of my nipples to the
bottom of my navel exposed yeah you know
prints were a waist chain mine was was
was was a belly chain you know he might
be you I had to get a jump rope go
around but it looked good
now you met Prince correct yeah yeah
yeah what's the story behind that you
know I I can't remember how we met
initially mmm but after our first
encounter he made sure that I was at
every house party that he had in Los
Angeles and if he knew that I was in
town that like in New York he made sure
that I was at every show he performed at
Madison Square Garden when he was in
Vegas he made sure that he because he
knows who comes to a show he does yeah
he knows
especially if he knows you and I would
get a call from his office from one of
his assistants and like Anthony Prince
is closing his show in Vegas next week
and he knows notice that you haven't
been come he wants to invite you and I
would I would come to the shows and I
would come and he would invite me
onstage man and we would have a great
time I never forget we were at Madison
Square Garden hmm security came to me to
my seat at the end of the show or
towards the end of the show and said
Prince wants you to come on stage I was
like okay he wants to come on stage now
all right so I'll go on stage me Whoopi
Goldberg Cornel West have a smiley a
bunch of other people on stage and we
went to this after-hours spot after the
concert a place called Village
Underground
in the George Shaw it's famous yeah and
so you know cuz Prince likes to jam
afterwards well Prince just went to go
listen to the musicians and so it's
Prince his assistant myself and I see
Prince leaned over to his assistant and
then all of a sudden that assistant
leans over to me and says I don't know
why I do this voice but as I stir Prince
wants you to come back and have pasta
and pizza I was like okay and then
Prince got up and left and she got up
and left I don't know why her voice is
so deep because it was a woman and and I
show up at the Ritz Carlton there's a
doorman there with the key his handsome
prince is on floor 42 and the room
numbers 4206 I was like okay gave me my
key put me in this private elevator I
went up put the key in the door the door
open to have my wife with me we walked
in was like oh and there was you know an
array of people in the living room and I
went back to fine prints and he was back
there holding court with Tavis Smiley
and Cornel West and he looked up and it
was like smile and gave me the peace
sign and I went back in and we had pasta
and pizza at four o'clock in the morning
how did Prince liked his pizza this is
very important the toppings first stars
a window into one so there was no meat
on the pizza and I didn't see Prince eat
any pizza
[Laughter]
we would go to his house man for the
house parties you know I wouldn't say
Prince was a vegan and so he had his
chef prepare you know you be you you be
at the house and it'd be Stevie Wonder
playing the piano uh Malcolm Jamal
Warner on bass
you know Rochelle Pharrell singing lead
you know Harry Connick jr. playing
bongos no no no that was a Mathieu
McConaughey confused sometimes it was
just amazing man and then you didn't
just like five o'clock in the morning
his chef was serving you breakfast
you like my princess house at five
o'clock in the morning man it was truly
an amazing relationship that not only
myself but other people had with him I'm
just glad that it was pizza and pasta
wasn't like a game of telephone like
princess to do something and then he
Prince wants you to come back to the
hotel and have pasta and pizza that's
how it came to me that is fantastic
now last one for you because I know you
gotta go is your your son is going to
Howard University
he's a freshman at Howard University
where you due to financial
considerations could not finish up by
you gonna put my parents business in the
street look so so what we didn't grow up
with a silver spoon like yourself Rich
Eisen anybody can afford University no
but you put yourself through school I
did and I ran out of money after my
junior year so I left after my junior
year always wanted to go back right I
had every intention on going back before
my children went to college my daughter
graduated [ __ ] laude from University of
San Diego this past May and this past
fall my son started his his freshman
year and I was like you know what at my
alma mater I was like you know what I'm
gonna go back I'm gonna go back so I
vowed to him and to myself that I will
walk with him in 2022 that's amazing
yeah but now Muslim may drop out after
his first semester
yeah are you serious unfortunately
hopefully he stays in hopefully stays in
school but my son is an aspiring rapper
and a young talented actor and he's had
unfortunately for him yes I'm his father
and he's had a taste of success early
you know he had a he's had two sitcoms
on Netflix that they didn't get picked
up but they lasted a year of peace and
he's made a nice chunk of money for a
seventeen-year-old okay
and he sees what I've been able to
accomplish as a college dropout and he
wants to follow that I was like no son
no son I didn't work this hard parenting
but to send you to private I know you
were gonna be a college dropout what is
it you the public school you could have
looked and seen Oh Elementary spend all
this money for Sierra Canyon ma'am he
was gonna be a college dropout you
didn't even need to go to high school
you could have been homeschooled well
maybe one day hopefully mate may your
child turn to his assistant work out I
Love You Man stay in school so we can
graduate together I was leaning to I
heard that story I thought it was such a
neat story yeah no that's that's my plan
hopefully and and and you know I joke
about it but I'm here to support my son
and whatever it is that he wants to do
he's an intelligent young man and you
know college isn't for everyone
you know you you can hope and want it to
be for your child but but it's not for
everyone they have their own path
Anthony Anderson I love when you're on
please come back soon you bet that's a
new drop on our show we got a game on
Twitter watch blackish Tuesdays 9:00
Eastern on ABC and get real about
diabetes calm for you to go check out
right now thanks for coming up oh thanks
for having you bet the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience